un coup de pinceau qui rappellerait
presque celui des impressionnistes il ne
s'agit pas d'un peintre du 19e siècle
mais de michel pédron sensible à la
nature michel a représenté le quotidien
des fermes et les animaux mais son
tableau préféré c'est celui du belem
c'était une commande
mon frère m'avait toujours demandé de
lui faire une marine à l'oissu fn marine
mais comme sue amoureux
ibm qui est éphémère et c'est sûrement
pour ça c'est ce que je préfère
je vais souffler ont montré c'était à mr
vraiment agité
j'ai aussi la mer je lui ai fait un
petit peu trop forte mais inciter
volontaires atteints de sclérose en
plaques depuis une vingtaine d'années
michel pédron voit dans la peinture un
moyen de s'échapper
il a créé ses premières toiles en 1974
et à persévérer malgré une maladie
endommageant le système nerveux
l'ehpad le format noir lui servira de
salle d'exposition pour la première fois
pendant un mois
l'objectif rendre l'art plus accessibles
aux résidents dans notre établissement
les personnes dont beaucoup de
difficultés à se déplacer à sortir vers
l'extérieur et donc là c'est
l'opportunité finalement de faire venir
l'extérieur dans l'établissement ceux-ci
promouvoir des artistes locaux en fait
leur permettre d'exposer dans notre
résidence qui est quand même un très
beau bâtiment à cause de sa maladie
michel ne peint plus depuis 2013 l'un de
ses derniers tableaux représentent un
portrait de son père pour autant il ne
souhaite pas abandonner envisage même
d'essayer de peindre avec la bouche
l'exposition est ouverte au public
jusqu'au 13 mars